like many honorable members i'm sure i'm
wrapped with a profound sadness at the
catastrophe that we've seen unfolding in
afghanistan
above all it is an unspeakable tragedy
for the people of that country who after
generations of conflict now live under a
terrible cloud of fear and repression
who could fail to be moved by the
agonizing scenes from kabul airport just
this week
how desperate must you have to be to
want to cling on to the side of a moving
aircraft
these past 20 years have been a struggle
for peace we tried to break the cycle of
war to give hope to women and girls we
tried to give the afghans a different
life one of hope and one of opportunity
but the catastrophic failure of
international political leadership
and the brutality of the taliban has
snatched all of that away from them
the new administration in kabul should
know that they will be judged not by
their words but by their actions
the world
is watching
and mr speaker i also want to reflect on
the service and the sacrifice of our
brave servicemen and women who
throughout
showed outstanding professionalism and
courage because the honourable member
from plymouth moore view said just a
moment ago
recent developments have hit them hard
they're grappling with the question
about whether all of the effort the
sacrifice was really worth it they're
again
grieving for falling comrades who didn't
come home
but whatever the outcome is in
afghanistan those men
and women and their families should be
proud of their service and we must be
proud of them
now many of us who served in afghanistan
have a deep bond of affection for the
afghan people
and i had the honor of serving alongside
them in helmand
we trained together
fought together and in some cases we
died together they were our brothers in
arms
but i shudder to think where those men
are now
many will be dead
others i know
now consider themselves to be dead men
walking
where were we in their hour of need we
were nowhere and that is shameful and it
will have a very long lasting impact on
britain's reputation right around the
world
i will give way to every day
my honourable friend fellow litigator is
absolutely right in his description of
the of the afghan armed forces will he
add to his comments uh now
that that many of them are more heroic
and better soldiers than they give them
credit for around the world
be grateful to the right honourable
gentleman as i always um i completely
agree with the point he made it was
particularly distasteful and dishonoring
a president biden to make reference to
the lack of courage and commitment by
those afghan soldiers who served with
such bravery and distinction
i think we have to be pragmatic and i
think at this difficult point we have to
think about what our next move is going
to be
and we should understand that the
character of our country is defined for
better or for worse by moments like this
we should also understand that we are
facing a moral and humanitarian crisis
of enormous proportions and the response
from the international community and
from the british government needs to
meet the magnitude of the moment
so
step up the statecraft engage with
international allies and alliances and
with regional partners and although it
is a particularly bitter pill to have to
swallow we must engage diplomatically
with a new regime in kabul it is in our
cold-headed national interest to do so
because right now our armed forces are
deployed on an operation to recover uk
nationals and other entitled personnel
it's in their interests that we engage
to try and ensure the safe passage of
those wanting to leave
but we also know that many many more
will want to get out and with our allies
we need to work to establish safe routes
to get them to safety we must show
compassion and genuine generosity to
refugees whilst accelerating and
expanding the arab scheme to support
those who supported us
we also need to defend the hard-won
progress over the past 20 years or so
girls in school women in parliament and
and in the judiciary we must ensure that
afghanistan does not slide back to where
it was
pre-1911
and then
when the dust settles
we need to look at what went wrong
and learn the lessons of this failure
why despite all of the effort we
couldn't build an afghan state
free from corruption with the legitimacy
and competence to balance the competing
forces within that country and what that
now means for our foreign and defence
policy in this
country regardless of all of that we
must remain engaged we must show
leadership we must use whatever
influence we have to try and make things
better that's in our own national
interest it's in line with our values
and it's the right thing to do
we owe that to the people of afghanistan
and we owe that to ourselves